[Music]
hello everybody i am josh welch
president of film independent and
welcome to a very special edition of
film independent presents
we are very excited to be having a
conversation today with
the filmmakers and the subject of the
documentary not going quietly um before
we get started i just want to share um
before we get started with today's q a i
want to give some praise to our loyal
supporters thank you to our incredible
lead sponsor the hollywood foreign press
association and thank you a deep deep
gratitude to our screening partner
vision media without whom none of this
would be possible
um so with that i want to get right to
welcoming i'm going to turn off my
alerts there
um let me start by welcoming uh director
nicholas brockman
hello nicholas
i'd like to welcome producer amanda
roddy
and executive producers the brothers
duploss mark and jay
um and then a very special welcome to
the subject of the documentary adi
barkin adi it's so nice to meet you and
thank you
for being here thank you to everyone for
being here today now i want to have a
chance to tell the story about my friend
addie barkin he's been an activist and
an organizer all of his life with us
today is artie parkett i can't do audi's
story justice i will let him tell it
i was
diagnosed with als today
[Music]
the knowledge that i was dying was
terrible
but dealing with my insurance company
was even worse
i wanted to spend every moment i had
left with rachel and carl
but then congress came after our health
care
the paradox of my situation is
the weaker i get
the louder i become
this is a film you know i watched this a
while ago and i feel like the world has
changed since i last saw the film and
nicholas had a chance to talk with you
about it um but maybe to kick things off
nicholas could you start just
telling the audience you know how you
came to do this film what what what
alerted you to adi and his work and what
was happening in the world when you
decided you and amanda decided to make
the film
yeah happy too josh and thanks to all
the film independent members out there
watching i do have to give a shout out
that film independent was a huge part of
my career in indie film i wouldn't be
here today if it wasn't for the programs
and labs and grants and all that good
stuff so your support went a long way to
making this movie happen
and i met audi in early 2018 like any
um good successful independent filmmaker
i also make commercials to
keep keep the lights on but we do
commercials for things that we really
care about political causes candidates
the biden campaign black lives matter
and i got the call in early 2018 from
liz jaff who had a mutual friend in
common with me on the obama campaign
and folks who've seen the film will
recognize her as audi's partner in crime
and she said i just met this guy on a
plane we're launching a health care
organization it was really crazy
confronted the senator went viral
we're going to make a move we're going
to make a movement out of it and i
really didn't know what to think at the
time i flew out to santa barbara to meet
audi i thought it was kind of one of
those like sally struthers ads where
somebody's like got an illness that is
trying to raise money and like the tiny
violin thing and when i met audi was
just absolutely anything but that he was
the funniest and most resilient and
craziest person i i knew and full of all
kinds of
dirty jokes and and foul-mouthed humor
which i later brought to mark and jay to
prove that this was going to be a really
really funny movie and to get them to
support it even though it's about more
than more than just that
and amanda and i um followed up on that
short video which was really just a
launch video a youtube ad and said to
audi and his family there's something
more here and and adi knew from from the
encounter that he just had with jeff
flake which really transfixed the whole
country that his story was powerful and
and he wasn't shy about it so a lot of
people ask us why did he agree and maybe
he'll speak to that
but it was actually an easy conversation
because audi really inherently
understands that the political is
personal and as a documentary filmmaker
i was so attracted to see what what he
had done with that short clip and we
wanted to expand on that in a film and
and that's where the journey began
nicholas could you just talk a little
bit more about that that what happened
on the plane and the inciting incident
that got you involved and sort of
what was the video
when you got involved that had already
happened and it had gone viral or what
was the
fill us in on that
yeah so adi had been a decade-long
activist uh long before he ever had als
and was incredibly influential before
that time
what happened though is that without his
whole life in front of him a beautiful
baby a beautiful wife and career in
progressive politics he was suddenly
stricken unexpectedly with als and he
was in a state of despair not knowing
what would happen with his family with
his career and then at the same moment
donald trump was elected president
dealing him this double blow that the
whole country felt adi gets on a plane
to go to dc to protest the tax cuts
which will cut into health care into
medicare and medicaid and he kind of
strikes out nobody really cares about
him he's in a wheelchair and on the way
back
dejected
he sees senator jeff flake the deciding
vote on this bill on the airplane
the woman next to him on the plane who
he's never met before points him out
they go together to have a conversation
with him the woman liz captures it on
video
post it to twitter and by the time the
plane lands audi has become the face of
the movement for universal healthcare
and one of the hugest progressive
activists pushing back on the trump
agenda and that's really where the story
begins
because they capitalize on that video
and launch this whole storytelling
movement
taking those kinds of cell phone videos
arming other sick disabled activists all
across the country to tell their stories
and and when you ask josh like what
attracted me to this story it was really
that it wasn't it wasn't adi he's very
attractive but it wasn't it wasn't so
much him but it was this idea of arming
people with storytelling tools to change
the country because that's what we do at
a macro level as filmmakers and he was
empowering regular people to do it and
they were [ __ ] winning which was
which was amazing to say that's
beautiful
um adi my next question is for you i you
know
i want to jump to the other end of the
process now where
since the film wrapped and it's come out
now theatrically and in all different
ways it feels like we're in a different
world politically than where the film
ends up maybe that's not true maybe
we're in the same world but it feels
like so much has changed with the
election
and um
just where we are culturally and
politically and i'm wondering if you
could talk about
where do you see the fight today if it's
different from where it was in the film
and what does your organization be a
hero focused on right now
and and how do you see where people can
make a real impact today
sorry it's a long question
before i answer your question i have one
for jay
is your cruel adobe hair natural
no
it's not natural uh but um
my daughter recently told me she said
i'm not ready for you to look older yet
but why does it look so good
so i don't know if i'm gonna do away
with it it's not natural but um we gave
her a hundred dollars to say that jay i
didn't want to tell you thank you so
much i really appreciate
the boost and confidence thank you body
um
adi i don't know if you wanted to
we can come back on that question if you
like
um
trying to promote
do you want them to move on adi no he's
gonna load it into his reader okay great
this is carmen i'm sitting next to him
thank you
by the way i am speaking to you from
next door to an elementary school so if
any of you here uh-huh i'm yelling that
is why ideal zoom circumstances yeah
as long as you play one or both of those
guitars at the end josh today
we'll bust them out yeah
boom
okay
hi and thank you for hosting this
discussion
these are some really great questions
you're right that our political
environment has changed since the movie
wrapped but our work today is just as
urgent as it was when trump was
president
it frankly is not enough to win
elections
the work of building a more just society
must continue after the race is won
so the fight today is to make good on
the promise of democratic control of the
federal government and bring
transformational change for the american
people right now
otherwise the trump fascists will come
back in two years and we will lose our
ability to govern
this past year my organization be a hero
has been focused on pushing congress and
the administration to deliver on
increased access to health care which
was central to why many people voted for
democrats in 2020.
we've specifically advocated for full
funding for home and community-based
services so that seniors and disabled
people aren't forced into unsafe nursing
homes and care workers can finally get a
truly living wage
i welcome people to join us in that
fight but really i encourage people to
get involved with the topic they care
most about
whether that be climate change or
immigration or workers rights
whatever it is join an organization
that's pushing for justice and help them
hold politicians accountable to the
changes they promised and everyday
people
thank you adi that's that's great to
hear and i i have to say it's
jen it's
genuinely inspiring to hear that because
the film ended very i mean the film
obviously the the there was a unknown
future to the film where the way it ends
and the sense of the work going on but
to hear you articulating in terms of
what's happening right now and where
people can be engaged and need to be
engaged feels like
it's great to hear it and it's just it's
it's truly inspiring to hear the work
continue beyond the scope of the film
um
amanda we i'd love to hear you talk a
bit about the sort of producing the film
and
give our listeners some sense of how
long you spent on the film and going on
the road with adi sort of what the
production
challenges and opportunities were there
yeah i'd be happy to talk about that um
i started on the film from the very
beginning when we got that initial call
from liz um who wanted to create a short
video for oddity hero campaign
and i think as soon as we started that
video like nick mentioned we realized
that body was someone special and he had
a really remarkable story and
we just knew that between him and liz
they were forced and they were going to
do something really cool
and so we were kind of on board from the
very beginning and taken with both of
them
and then they told us you know a month
they're too into filming these political
ads that they wanted to rent an rv and
travel across the country and we're like
oh my god that sounds awesome so we also
rented an rv and followed them across
the country and started making a bunch
of political ads with them um
and that was an incredible experience it
also came with a lot of producing and
creative challenges
getting five people working together in
an rv following a separate group of
five people who were working on
political organizing um was really
challenging and they were
audi and liz and helen and nate they all
had a really rigorous schedule and um
we couldn't slow them down so
we had to be really quick and on our
feet with all of their planning trying
to figure out what their next moves were
and what was important for us to film
not only to help them create political
ads which is what we were doing on the
side as well as kind of going over time
to create additional content for this
documentary to get a real
behind-the-scenes look and more personal
look at what they were doing
and also being mindful of the fact that
you know
audi is doing a lot of work his voice
was
rapidly declining and we wanted to make
sure that he was able to reserve some of
that for his family for the work that he
loved doing and um
we always had to kind of check in with
each other um and with their team to
make sure that um we were getting what
we needed for them for their ads
for the future documentary and also
giving everyone um a certain amount of
space so that was that was definitely a
challenge and just required a lot of
communication but i think one of the
benefits of
having rented an rv and followed
following them along for about two
months straight was that um we got to
build a relationship with them pretty
quickly early on which was pretty
critical in terms of
setting out to do this larger film
because initially we thought that this
would be just about the midterm
elections because we thought this rv
road trip was going to be
plenty of material but then you know a
few months later audi started to uh
protest the kavanaugh nomination anna
maria confronted jeff flake
um and then more and more amazing stuff
happened like audi testified in front of
congress he met with almost all the
democratic presidential candidates and
we were just kind of we had our minds
blown
by all of that and realized that we kind
of had to continue um filming so
we uh
took a lot of our cues from them um and
kind of tried to
adapt the way that we told the story by
learning from them
and
communicating with them and having
fostering a close relationship so that
we could um
do all of that so i hope that
that really kind of somewhat answers
your question of some of the producing
challenges and how we approach this film
and how the rv road trip actually really
helped us in terms of um yeah building
that relationship that we might have
otherwise wouldn't have
i mean it's amazing to hear that story
of the rvs and it definitely pays off in
the in the film itself i feel like i
mean to me
i love a lot of things about the film
but it's it's on the one hand it's a
story of about an activist audi and and
the issues the political issues the
moment that we're in but it's also this
intensely personal um portrait and story
where
it's such immediate intimate filmmaking
in the best sense and adi i have a
question for you on this i mean the film
is so personal and intimate revealing
everything you're going through
personally and medically and also with
your family
and i'm i'm just curious you know now
that the film is out
um
what has your experience been
sort of your your takeaway from going
through this experience of being filmed
in that way and i'm really curious if
you've had the chance to watch the film
with an audience
it's been surreal to see my life and
that of my family up on the big screen
i watched it with an audience over the
summer at the premiere in los angeles
that was a really beautiful moment for
me and other comrades in the progressive
movement to come together reflect on the
last couple of years and strategize for
the journey ahead
so having the movie out has been really
powerful just in terms of absorbing both
privately and publicly how much has
changed for me and my family over the
last few years
and how far the entire progressive
movement has come since 2016.
yeah
that's um
that's great to hear
um
uh to jay and mark i now want to ask you
so
first of all
the duplass brothers i feel like during
the pandemic i have watched so much
great things that you guys have been out
there creating whether it's language
lessons or lady in the dale there's you
guys are you make me feel very lazy
uh with everything that you're doing but
um i would love to hear in the midst of
everything that you're working on how
you got involved in this project and
what when you got involved in and really
what drew you to it
uh i guess a couple of years ago um
adi and i have a really close personal
friend in common bradley whitford
television's bradley whitford that is
um who you know came to mark in me and
said look uh there are these two
filmmakers who are you know making a
very grassroots documentary about adi
barkin
um
and you know mark and i i mean
essentially it was two people making a
film at the core of it it's something
that mark and i obviously have a lot of
experience with and feel a kinship with
and when we found out about the material
and in particular
just this idea that
you know trump's presidency and policies
were
literally
threatening adi's life it just felt so
immediate
so obvious that we wanted to be involved
and just help these people tell their
story
but like you were saying the world has
changed so much in the last three years
i guess since
we started talking to to these guys
about it
and i i mean i even personally have had
you know of course there's like adi's
personal story in his journey with als
and how that interfaces with the
healthcare situation that we've
we've been in for quite a while now that
needs so much help uh but i think
what has emerged at least for me is just
the importance of um fighting for our
democracy
uh which
i guess is really the most
timeless part of all of this for me
personally i don't know about you mark
i mean i definitely knew when i heard
about the story i wanted to support i
honestly felt a little
insecure about coming on because the
movies that jay and i have traditionally
executive produced in the past we have
felt like
we're here to help we know exactly what
to do
and how to make low-budget narrative
films that's what we do
what we don't exactly know how to do
is make this incredible grassroots
political documentary on a subject as
complicated as health care which we
don't have the
education and experience with to come on
and say this is exactly how you do it
right and and i remembered a friend of
mine told me something that i loved
which is
when you want to get involved just swing
the sword that you have in your hand
don't worry about the one that you don't
have and jay and i talked about it and
we were like okay
nick and amanda and adi are the experts
here and what we can offer is
you know a platform whatever we have to
get this movie out there and we can give
them
luckily some of the cash we've been able
to make in this industry and support
them
um and and use our mouthpiece to help
get it out there and it's and it was
really emboldening to me to know that i
could be helpful without being an expert
in this area and just use
the pieces that i had
and it's been really
just personally very enriching for me to
be able to be a part of something like
this where
i'm not the expert but at least i can
throw a couple of cogs in there and it's
taught me a lot about how i want to move
forward as a collaborator with with
other projects
can i ask my gosh about working with
these guys
yeah please great well i just want to
say that you know in addition to the
cash and great hair that these guys
added to the product
working with them
was really integral to me creatively
because
it was really important to i mean
obviously when i you know grew up
watching you know puppy chair and these
guys films but also because
i really wanted this to have a driving
cinematic and really narrative quality
which i hope we achieve there's no you
know despite these guys not being
experts myself neither there's no
experts in the film talking about health
care except variety of course there's no
talking head interviews and um there's a
lot of comedy and uplift in the film and
i really want audiences to know that
because it's difficult subject matter
but working with these guys we did a lot
of rough cut screenings in there in
their office in la and part of all of
our conversations were about how do we
bring like the joy and celebration and
humor and really when we started working
with audi that's what the film was it
wasn't just like he's this great
activist you know the first thing we
ever filmed with him adi had his shirt
off he's topless we were like hadn't
rolled a single frame and audi's like
all right let's do the thing you know
with his like nipples out and that was
the moment for me that i was like
there's a movie here and so in working
with mark and jay a lot of it was about
how do we reinforce those narrative
qualities to the film and that is
something that they're experts in and i
think really helped shape the cut into
what what it became ultimately
that's great yeah i mean the
the humor and the tone of the film
really do set it apart from so many
documentaries that could have done
something much drier and more formal and
i feel like it just brings us to life in
in a way that serves
the story overall and and the the deeper
subject matter too
mark i love that line of uh
i'm gonna get it wrong but use whatever
sword you have in your hand that's a
great
line that i feel like embodies the
the activism of body and everyone
involved but also of independent film
right i mean that's how
that's how we work as independent
filmmakers um you use the sword you have
i've always i've always loved that that
spirit that um you know it
it's very intimidating to take that
first step into something um and i think
that when you watch
what audi has done when you watched what
you know his comrades and arms have done
in this field
um there there is a kinship that jay and
i felt spiritually to
us being 23 and 27 years old and and not
knowing how to become filmmakers and and
realizing that we were just going to
have to sort of um cascade ignorantly
down the mountain and figure it out as
we went um and i think if there's
anything i want to encourage to people
while watching this or who are inspired
by this it's you know please don't feel
like you need to be an expert or even
particularly well adept at what it is
that you're passionate about raise your
hand um and there are people around you
who can point you in the right direction
i mean all it really takes is is the
desire and i i i think i let that stop
me for a little while um
and i'm i'm
glad that i learned through this film
that it really shouldn't
yeah
um so i have another question for you
adi which is um it kind of dovetails off
what mark was just saying but i feel
like today
there's so much talk of our political
system being fundamentally broken or
democracy is you know
going away
and
it's easy to give in to despair in this
moment i mean partly i think out of
exhaustion with everything's going on
but also just
despair overs it seems like things are
really broken in a way that maybe they
haven't been before and i'm just i'd
love to hear you talk about that
how uh to put it
boldly how hopeful or unhopeful do you
feel about the democratic process today
and and
i think i know the answers but do you
see avenues for real and positive change
given everything that's going on right
now
that's an interesting question
it's true that our democracy is in grave
danger
republicans are actively trying to
prevent people of color from voting a
group of insurrectionists violently
overtook the capital and people are
struggling to access basic resources
like healthcare
yet i have hope
but hope as rebecca solid says is not
passive but rather a spur to action
hope is not a lottery ticket that we
cling to it's a hammer that we use in an
emergency to break the glass
sound the alarm and spring into action
hope is not a state of mind it's a state
of action
so yes i have hope and i think there's a
lot of opportunities for real change
where we need to channel that hope
we can pass a green new deal to save the
planet enact medicare for all to
guarantee everyone the health care they
deserve rewrite the rules of our economy
to make it fairer for workers and more
but it will all depend on the american
people rising to the challenge
we are the authors of that collective
future
we hold the pen
wow
thank you
i love that
the idea that hope is an action not not
just a feeling that's really
that's amazing um well nicholas i want
to end with a
question well it's really for anyone but
i'll direct it to you nicholas which is
um
uh
so that i was on your website the other
day for the film and it's a beautiful
website and it's it is it's
it's like it's actually where you can
see the film but also where you can do
so much more so i guess this is
piggybacking what audi was just saying
but for the film how do you see it what
life do you want the film to have right
now obviously you want people to watch
it but beyond that i feel like there's
it's it's
you're trying to drive people into
action so can you talk about that and
kind of the the goal that you have with
this film in terms of impact
yeah i mean it's been an amazing journey
with the film so far this year it was
supposed to come out last year but as
with so many things it was delayed audi
had his ticket to come out to the
tribeca film festival in 2020 and of
course that didn't happen instead we
spent the whole year working on the film
and when it ultimately came out we
actually thought oh this has to come out
during the trump administration has to
sway the election but as adi said
uh in this conversation that actually
it's not enough to win elections you
have to hold the politicians accountable
and that's what he's doing right now and
that's what we hope the film will
support so one thing we want people to
do at home is just to watch the movie
tell their friends if they didn't see it
tonight at film independent it's
available now on all the vod platforms
we've been getting amazing recognition
from from the awards uh of various
platforms including adi being recognized
as most compelling living subject of a
documentary to which he said it's better
than the alternative which we which we
agree and um you know we want that word
to get out because ultimately people in
the industry seeing the film will help
it um kind of raise the prominence of it
but the ultimate goal is not um to win
awards the ultimate goal is to drive
adi's movement forward we're so grateful
that he's with us today doing this work
and more powerful than he was when we
met him we never could have expected as
amanda was saying that we'd have an
audience with kamala harris and and
bernie sanders and joe biden who were
trying to get audi's attention to get
his approval and his buy-in to the to
the work that they were doing and adi
has a very powerful sword to swing right
now and so
we want people to get involved in these
um fights for democracy at large that
we've been talking about but you can
also join adi's movement right now at
join adi.com and be part of the be a
hero movement which is doing the work
that it was doing in the film you can
get involved in the fight for medicare
for all get involved in the fight for
the
home care funding to be included in the
build back better infrastructure bill
which will keep people like adi in their
home and out of nursing homes this fight
is going on right now both at the kind
of local and legislative level right now
and then we have this decade-long battle
to win hopefully less to finally win
medicare for all part of the work that
adi has done has made it so that today a
majority of americans support a
universal healthcare program so it's all
just about closing that gap between what
our elected representatives are doing
and what we want through bird dogging
through activism um and through uh
joining adi in this movement so those
are some of the ways that folks can get
involved and and see the film
amazing well i should i want to i want
to thank you all for being here today
talking to you i mean watching the film
again and being able to talk to you just
it leaves me first of all so excited
about documentary film and what it can
do and the like thinking back to when
you how the film came together when
there's that jeff flake video to where
you are today and knowing the
the impact that this film can have and
amplifying adi's work and and even
beyond that is just
really inspiring about the power of good
storytelling and
on a personal level i just want to say i
love when
good people make good movies right
there's like
this is an amazing group of filmmakers
and storytellers and activists and um so
to anyone watching this um please do
spread the word about the film drive
people to the website
um and uh let's let's continue on and
see where this
where this film takes us but uh thank
you all so much for being here today and
adi it's wonder it's really an honor to
meet you thank you thank you for being
here as well
thanks so much josh thanks josh
thank you
thanks mark and jay for all the support
thank
talk to you all soon
[Music]